we've got a story from national review
this is kind of an update to a story
we've talked about over the years
um it says a texas jug judge texas jug
has granted full custody of
eight-year-old james younger to his
mother who has
fought publicly to transition her son
into a girl
against the father's wishes judge mary
brown granted full custody to anne
georgelus
in an order on tuesday awarding the
mother exclusive control over james
primary residence counseling medications
education
and extracurricular activities it allows
georgialists to withhold information
from jeff younger james's father
regarding the children's extracurricular
activities school functions school
enrollment counseling and medical care
however while george elis has the
exclusive right to consent to james
medical procedures
the order notes that the power does not
extend to hormone suppression therapy
puberty blockers
or transgender reassignment surgery
the high profile custody case has played
out publicly for years as george lewis
has insisted that her son identifies as
a girl named luna
and as i said we've talked about this
this goes back
um to when james was only three years
old
and that's when according to james
younger that's when his wife decided
that little james is actually a girl
eventually they get divorced
and there's been this custody battle
ever since then
with james younger who
what other details about his life you
know i don't know i don't know him
personally
i'm sure he's not a perfect person
nobody is
um but one thing is for certain
he knows that his boy is a boy and he
believes that his boy has a right to
live as a boy and to not have this
confusion imposed on him
which will do un it already has done i i
hate to say it has already done
untold potentially lifelong damage
and only knowing that about j uh
rather james younger is the child only
knowing that about the father
jeff younger you know jeff younger
versus anne georgeless if the only thing
we know
is that anne georgelis wants to convert
the boy into a girl
and jeff younger is saying absolutely
not don't do that we already know that
jeff younger is the more fit parent
and it it wouldn't be hard to claim that
title because
if if you want to transition your boy
into a girl you are you are simply not
fit
you can't be you shouldn't be allowed
anywhere near that child
in a just insane society there would be
no controversy here at all
during the custody battle you would you
would go to court and the dad would say
she's putting my son in dresses and
calling him luna and trying to tell him
he's a girl
and the judge would say okay the kid the
kid goes to jeff
end of discussion oh by the way you're
not allowed within 500 yards of that
child not only do you not get custody
you can't see him or be near him you
lunatic
this is a form of psychological and
sexual abuse yes it is sexual abuse
um that is previous generations would
have looked on this
and in in unspeakable
horror unable to even understand what
they're watching
this is definitely something to keep in
mind um i
i hear from speaking of single people i
hear from single people all the time
looking for you know a match out there
and it's it's it can be difficult in
this culture
to find that especially as a
conservative or a christian to find
someone who shares your values
and uh i hear from young men saying how
do i find a good woman
and women saying that about men well i
tell you one thing
um here's one question you should ask
very early on before you even consider
marriage or anything whether you're a
woman
you know dating a man or mandating a
woman
one of the first questions you ask early
on should be on this topic
do you think it would ever be possible
there's ever a scenario
when a little boy should be raised as a
girl
i would pose that question and if you
get anything
other than an absolutely hell no
run in the opposite direction
this is one of the most horrifying
things to think about
that you get married to someone and you
have a kid and then they
do this to your kid
and it would be bad enough in a sane
society if that were to happen
but at least then all you have to do is
go get you got to get the divorce
and you'll get custody because you
married a crazy person
[Music]
but now you know our whole system is
against you they're going to be on the
side
of your spouse doing this to your child
so there's a question you know what i
would pose that on the first date
be one of the first things i would ask
you're going to scare a lot of people
away that way that's all for the better
because i wouldn't even consider it this
is a risk i would not take
[Music]
i would want to know that you are firmly
against this and there is
no chance that you would ever even
consider it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated